10% of black men have What's called the
super Gene the super Gene is ability to
put on muscle without fat only 1% of
caucasians have it 75% plus of self-made
billionaires were born to wealthy
parents but that does not mean their
parents gave them the money the way I
interpret that as genetics you can
inherit warlord genes read the selfish
Gene by Richard Dawkins nothing I can do
will make me Shaquille O'Neal 7'2
dominant basketball player you can't
change him why do you think that's such
an unpopular opinion narcissism's on the
rise do you think it's a narcissistic
trait to want to think that you can
change your environment epigenetics has
some truth to it but it's been latched
on to by people as like well you can
change your jeans what the are you
talking about is a black man GNA turn
white Michael Jackson has entered the
chat yeah did it work